free movement around Europe has been the
most popular achievement of the European
Union according to surveys now that
freedom has been reinforced in a deal
struck by negotiators for the European
Parliament the Commission and member
state governments the plan is to prevent
any unauthorized border checks we are
speaking in Europe about free movement
and the government's they don't have the
chance in according with the law to
include to impose controls in internal
borders all in exceptional circumstances
it is allowed during the twenty eleven
arab spring when refugees fled conflict
in north africa some EU states
re-imposed border controls and call for
the right to do so wherever they felt it
necessary in future such controls will
require consultation with the European
Parliament but Emmy peas will not have
the power to block them as they'd wanted
for I'm guida son stormed us cleanse
control nishta dying if you were to be
adding ausfahrt and Chinese Gordon only
tried to escape the bar like pure
government pooh-bah this is I'm gone
crushed you want us boiled outpost in BO
the azienda stomach anger tested in
theory controls can only be reintroduced
if there's a threat to national security
or Public Order and strict criteria will
apply an evaluation mechanism for
emergencies and common rules on the
circumstances in which temporary checks
can be brought in but illegal checks are
still carried out now and mep s hope
snap inspections will stamp that out
member states for internal security
reasons they have the right to impose
controls exceptionally if they feel the
need what they cannot do its to do that
very often that means as a regular way
and now we have the tools to assess if
they are not respecting the law
negotiations have taken more than a year
and although in theory the deal allows
for bulgaria and romania to join the
Schengen area it's not clear if some
existing members will allow it